there's a mod for Red Dead Redemption 2
that lets you play as any animal in the
game's ecosystem and it is quite
literally a transformative experience
with this mod I tore through a town as a
deer and I raced through the grass as a
mountain lion and I soared through the
skies as an eagle and through it all I
gained a new understanding of a world I
thought I was already deep familiar with
I knew this virtual ecosystem was
vibrant but by changing my perspective I
realized it's
alive some worlds feel like they exist
long before you press play when a game
pulls this off the results can be
breathtaking and sometimes even a little
uncanny so let's discover what makes the
digital ecosystem Tru truly seem to have
a life of its
own even without mods that expand your
perspective the world of Red Dead is
obsessively detailed snow realistically
Falls from branches as you wander past
the eyes of owls glow in the dark
depending on the ambient temperature
there's realistic growth and shrinkage
of your horses okay we're skipping that
but it proves my point this game's
commitment to environmental minutia is
absurd which is probably why playing as
an animal genuinely feels like a kind of
existential Voyage I don't want to OV
exaggerate but I mean it when I say this
game is so immersive it's hard not to
Lose Yourself within each New
Perspective every animal made me see the
ecosystem a different way and
re-evaluate my position within
it inhabiting different roles in an
ecosystem is even more essential to a
game like lost Ember developed by an
indie Studio the entire experience
revolves around changing forms choosing
the perfect time to transfer your
Consciousness into a different Link in
the food chain you play as a soul
Wanderer a reincarnated spirit that can
periodically take over the bodies of
nearby life forms to navigate a hostile
environment it's a little tricky to get
the hang of it first but the more you
practice the more natural it becomes to
constantly be changing between different
modes of existence no two species feel
the same being a wombat is a leisurely
experience while being a hummingbird is
frantic fitting for an animal with a
heart that beats over a thousand times
per minute and since every creature has
their own terrain their Adept at
navigating you can never settle into to
one form for too long like in Red Dead
the multiple perspectives give you a
greater understanding of the larger
ecosystems to the point where it's
impossible to imagine the game without
this mechanic but here's what's weird
the shape-changing feature isn't
actually supposed to be in Red Dead at
all and yet like lost Ember it feels
fundamental for example while playing
this mod I realized that every bird
takes off slightly differently it even
seems that heavy species like Condors
can't take off directly from the ground
and need a realistically elevated
position to soar through the skies but
pretty much the only time you see birds
in this game is from a great distance on
Horseback so why include these
intricacies this doesn't add any
animations all these elements were here
in the base game just waiting to be
uncovered each bird also has a
distinctive flight pattern except for
bats which have their own completely
unique flight system I didn't even know
there were bats in this game I've never
seen one before I've beaten it
twice what compels a studio to focus
this much on Tiny details details that
the vast majority of players are never
going to uncover if any game can help
help us answer that question it has to
be D Fortress quite possibly the most
labyrinthine and complicated title ever
conceived the product of almost 20 years
of work by a pair of brothers every time
you press start the game generates a new
world calculating rainfall and mineral
distribution and temperature and
elevation and a hundred other things you
can watch thousands of years of
simulated history flicker by a timeline
of events generated in the top Corner
chronicling War and treaties and
betrayals and losses and that's just the
Abridged version the full history of my
first game included 5
2,086 events all before I started
playing trying to actually beat dor
Fortress Is potentially even more
complicated but I think that bewildering
intricacy is the point to an extent in
the original Tex based game you manage
countless entities represented by
letters which can be overwhelming but
also mesmerizing I know I'll never fully
comprehend this gargantuan biion network
but that just makes it feel more like an
actual world the kind of ecosystem you
could spend a lifetime
studying of course you could also spend
a lifetime studying the smallest
ecosystem ant simulation is the Pinnacle
of specificity created by YouTuber peza
it's incredible how thoroughly this
project replicates the movements of real
insects every simulated worker leaves
behind a chemical path just like in
nature to guide their nestmates to
sources of food two different colonies
of ants will fight over the same
resources the conflict realistically
breaking off into numerous skirmishes
ant simulator doesn't boast thousands of
years of lore like d Fortress and yet
the interactions feel no less important
proving that a Micro World can be just
as impactful as a macro one this is true
in other digital ecosystems as well
there's a reason why players are so
excited to find Ants in Skyrim a title
where you regularly fight
dragons sometimes it's the smallest
details that make an ecosystem feel
alive take mud for instance okay hear me
out on this the mud in Red Dead is
beautiful the way people and animals and
carts all leave tracks through it add so
much to the environments if you
accidentally fall into the mud it gets
all over your clothes it seems so
physical which is why was surprised to
learn it's flat and not just flat
because it's on a TV screen I mean flat
compared to the rest of the games 3D
rendering people have gone into the
files and discovered this mud is just a
2d texture with the Deep Footprints all
a clever optical illusion and that's not
a bad thing you can't really render a
virtual ecosystem on current Hardware
without carefully allocating resources
but I think it's a noteworthy Paradox
that many of the worlds that feel most
most alive are constantly culling things
out the beautiful Rippling grasses of
games like tears of the Kingdom can only
exist because the world is lowering the
quality of plants that are further away
in fact for most modern games any part
of the terrain that isn't within the
player's immediate cone of vision is
being constantly rendered out and again
I want to make it clear none of these
techniques are bad without them most
digital ecosystems couldn't exist at all
so why is it that I feel slightly uneasy
when I learn that a game like Insomniac
Spider-Man contains thousands tens of
thousands of false environments the vast
majority of Interiors you can see
through windows in this game are
Illusions completely flat images like
red Dead's mud made to look full of
depth through a clever trick of
programming it's a conceit that makes
total sense New York in this game is an
urban ecosystem just as detailed as any
biological one there's no way the
developers could render every single
apartment I know that and yet there's
still something strange to me about
peering into a space and knowing it's
not
there this strangeness isn't unique to
game environments movies have been using
similar techniques for decades creating
numerous Fantastical ecosystems through
well-placed flat images the traditional
film method for creating imagined
environments was the matte painting
which was combined with liveaction
footage in the days before CGI the
original Star Wars Trilogy made use of
techniques like this a lot with numerous
scenes merging sets with paintings in
ways that are almost impossible to
notice it really is something of a lost
worldbuilding art it's likely you've
seen some landscapes in movies you
haven't even realized were paintings
even still you might have felt something
was off a slight nagging sense of
unreality and of course in some cases is
it's easier to tell than others with the
very seams visible if you look
closely the seams in Virtual Eco systems
typically aren't as obvious but you can
spot them too if you know what to look
for any moment in a modern game that
requires you to stop and move through a
tight space is probably buying time to
load in the next area this strategy is
honestly pretty clever and shows how
carefully streamlined Virtual Worlds
have to be maybe that's why when a game
includes useless details like ants or
overly specific flight animations it
feels so revelatory like you turned
around too fast and instead of catching
the seams you caught the game being
alive in a way it shouldn't this is a
huge part of why the ecosystem of a game
like rain world seems to have a life of
its own in that title creature
interactions are simulated even when you
aren't on screen which means you'll
constantly stumble upon unfolding dramas
that have nothing to do with your
journey it feels like the world simply
exists far beyond the confines of the
camera if there's a film equivalent to
this kind of environment it's probably
the expansive
360° physical set which are becoming
increasingly rare though less practical
than a static backdrop or green screen
these types of sets have a total
immersion quality I find extremely
compelling these are worlds that people
actually built and walked through like
the Roman form from the film Cleopatra
an absolutely monstrous construction
that bankrupted the studio its
proportions were more than double that
of the actual Roman form and since this
film was a financial bomb it's also
something of a monument to the hubristic
end of old Hollywood a historical site
in its own right though not one that
survived to present day I also think of
the atle set from Waterworld which was a
quarter mile in circumference production
of this movie reportedly swallowed up up
every piece of Steel in Hawaii requiring
more to be flown in from California this
film was also a financial
bomb you might question what such
anecdotes have to do with video game
ecosystems but I think there's a real
commonality across these obsessive
attempts at crafting convincing
fictional environments perhaps it's a
natural creative inclination to Chase
the Dream of an imagined world without
boundary it can also clearly be
disastrous and even and
dangerous at what point does a fictional
world stop being fictional this is a
question essential to the production of
Da what began as a single movie turned
into a two-year-long experiment where
over a thousand actors and Extras lived
in a closed off replica of Cold War era
Russia whether on or off camera the
people on set had to remain fully in
character working actual jobs for period
appropriate currency this Truman Show
like simulation was 12,000 square miles
the largest set ever built in Europe and
the institutional corruption the movie
grapples with reportedly spilled over
into life on the set with allegations of
mistreatment surrounding the production
and despite all these efforts to create
an authentic setting the movie isn't
even supposed to be very
good did you know that there's over a
thousand unique characters in Red Dead
the vast majority exist in the
background full-time extras in a digital
set their sole purpose to make the
environments you walk through more
lifelike yet if you decide to follow one
throughout their day you'll find most of
these digital people have a full daily
routine they wake up each morning and go
to work some toil away for long hours
others slack off when they can when
night falls people amble home at
different speeds some have families to
get back to others seem achingly lonely
early in this video I said that worlds
that seem like they exist before you
press play can feel uncanny red Dead's
world with its almost unhinged Devotion
to realism can certainly fall into that
category left unchecked the pursuit of a
living fictional world can be a kind of
Madness you can see this quite plainly
across the multi-decade career of game
designer Peter molanu a founding
influence in the so-called God game
genre his project objects frequently
give you command of not just ecosystems
but entire worlds and are usually
ambitious to the point of collapsing
under their own weight the cleopatras
and water worlds of gaming there's a
reason why not many other Studios have
even attempted to make games like this
trying to make Worlds at this level of
complexity can often lead to setbacks
and broken promises that said a part of
me sympathizes with how molanu desire to
create outpaces what he can actually
produce
the wildly anticipated fa famously
claimed players could plant an acorn and
watch it grow into a tree over the
course of the game a feature that had to
be cut in the final
version the game Yonder The Cloud
catcher Chronicles was not produced by
mullu yet as writer Matt ppri points out
in his review of the title in that game
you actually can watch acorns grow into
trees which is impressive because Yonder
is a small indie project but one with a
strong sense of the kind of world it
wants to build the map is Tiny the
creature variety limited yet yonder's
ecosystem feels more fully realized than
many big budget titles I think it's an
intriguing contrast to Dow style Mega
projects suggesting that not all worlds
need a thousand layers of detail to feel
alive do red Dead's intricacies make the
game better I mean don't get me wrong
they certainly do part of the time these
might be the most most stunning
environments I've ever had the pleasure
of exploring but on the other hand
sometimes the excess feels like well
excess I think one detail in particular
sums up this dichotomy the best and it's
probably one you've never noticed the
stars in Red Dead shine ever so slightly
more brightly in the wilderness than
they do in urban areas which is accurate
but also what a detail to
include on the one hand it seems crazy
to bother with adding such a subtle
realworld imperfection but on the other
hand I think it's kind of perfect
because Red Dead Redemption 2 isn't just
a game about exploring a breathtaking
world it's also about the end of one
rapid industrialization changed the very
landscape of the United States expanding
cities and Railways replace forests and
Fields destroying and displacing
Indigenous communities all these themes
are present in the game's lengthy story
but they're also present in the land
itself even when you're not in a city
there's a transient quality to the
game's ecosystems a sense that none of
this will remain as it is not even the
Stars I felt this dimming of a natural
era most strongly when inhabiting the
perspective of animals which is again
really weird because none of that is
meant to be in the game but trying to
steer a buffalo through an urban area is
so visually and mechanically powerful it
instills a feeling in your animal bones
that this is a world that no longer
belongs to you maybe it's silly to read
this much into a fan-made add-on but I
think it's a testament to how thorough
this world is that it can serve as a
canvas for experiences the developers
never
intended having said all this I do think
there needs to be some kind of Reckoning
with the fact that these ecosystems
don't always work perfectly I've
recorded a lot of game footage for this
Channel and one thing I always edit out
are glitches moments where creatures
freak out or just behave in an unusual
manner even the most impressive virtual
biospheres have these sorts of hiccups
when it comes to immersion glitches are
almost universally regarded as a
negative but in a strange way I think
they can sometimes make a world feel
more realistic nature doesn't always act
rationally just look at the comedy
Wildlife photography awards
a contest where the top nature
photographers share photos of animals
essentially glitching out animals aren't
always perfect at being animals in real
life so it's kind of fitting the same as
true in the virtual realm for example I
had a lot of trouble recording footage
of bears in Red Dead for this video
because some problem with their code
meant they would just not do what I
wanted but I think that's kind of
appropriate Bears don't like doing what
people tell them to they're
bears
I'm not sure any ecosystem embodies the
playful side of nature better than the
one in Alba a wildlife Adventure the
final title I want to discuss today Alba
is something of the spiritual and
mechanical opposite of a game like Red
Dead its world is bright and stylized
instead of grim and realistic instead of
playing as an outlaw you play as a kid
trying to document all the animals on an
island and the map itself is really tiny
a carefully curated Slice of Life you
even have a little book full of all the
wildlife you can find it's really
Charming which is why it's a surprise to
learn that this world to is coming to an
end you find out early on in the game
that all these environments will be
replaced to make room for a hotel
development and as you might imagine
this world's fate isn't as unalterable
as the fate of the United States in Red
Dead I mean it's a kids game but it's
telling that the creators felt the need
to include this element I don't really
think you can craft an ecosystem Centric
story without themes of ecological
destruction seeping in even lost Ember
which takes place in a Fantasy Realm
radically Divergent from our own subtly
explores the tension between nature and
Humanity through its story of a fallen
civilization these are ideas you can't
really Escape even if there's something
only felt in the
background but in games with living
ecosystems the backgrounds become the
foregrounds I know this is an aspect of
Red Dead that frustrated some people I
mean the game is advertised as this
action Centric Cowboy adventure and it
is that for some of the time but at
least 60% of this game is just riding
your horse through natural Vistas on my
first playthrough that seemed like a
weird allocation of time but now I'm not
so sure in environment focused games it
is the backdrop the minutia and all
those little pointless details that
become become the whole point my
experiences with these worlds have
stayed with me there's something I carry
around in the jumble of my thoughts long
after I pressed the power button and
turned off these ecosystems for good
they've continued to have a life of
their own these worlds linger they're
alive and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next
video